Kevin working on some Kevin zombie crush  it  Bobby smashing in face yeah it's a bit  sticky Wow that's disgusting pretty  disgusting walk past something like this  on the table you have to touch it yeah  yeah so much stuff this is just like  like fun house who is this guy  what does this do tell me about these  guys I thought those were vaginas sup  see so great it's a good look I like the  bigger nose for you what what do you do  with this when they rip it open though  reveal that's awesome rib cage just a  little bit of muscle our space from  preacher butthole face I can scare the  little people with us take it I like his  style  all right  there's your figure  [Music]  this we're and I'm so used to I'm so  yeah to me it's super weird  they're holding I'll take a picture of  you taking picture of you  [Music]  end up my hat back one glasses well so  creepy